Shepard with the rebound fuss look at
him go look at deer in photo like that
like NBA basketball
boy we talk about electricity look at
that move and pagli the recipient of
that great assist that's 13 assists for
the Aaron Fox
I think that's fatigue : o how best will
hat
where did [ __ ] there's so much this how
many how many dribbles three dribbles in
a boat come this way box all the way to
the red uses link down bounces back to
it knocked away and stolen by the Aaron
Fox he is off to the races and dumpster
there he's got speed down a few seconds
box to the lane and it's knocked away
six Pacers turnover Fox got it six-point
lead I'm telling you that was one
difficult shot it got a delay a game on
Sacramento I mean this is a difficult
shot to make look at all this contact
and hang time and it still gets it up
there and it just scrapes on the realm
and he missed it
that's 11 per per box oh well my
goodness
just tell the shot clock operated to go
home
Fox was talking to the official coming
down before as if he was found I
couldn't see from where my vantage point
was but it doesn't matter it's now Fox
coming the other way
no one's catching the Aaron Fox 105
before 55 nice defense there let's see
if the Kings can get a couple of baskets
in succession Fox yep
and I catch the crowd alive 64 57
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's three or plus for Miami nice play
the Aaron Fox off-balance never took his
eye off the square it's there he spots
barnesworth Rico
box with the rebound he is going that's
what he could do hot by Harris I
recognize Buddy hield was trying to
gamble raced everybody a lot of bodies
ran right behind same token lying arch
of the act nose down garden you got a
garden I mean if you you you're their
guard up footsteps in the line and get
the bounce Thompson kept it alive
controlled though by the speed demon Fox
gets the ball get ended as quick as
anybody in this little devils with three
guys are gonna do you want to does his
Fox on the steal an easy score he's
lightning quick you can tell this team
Fred use that of his trick this team yep
again the Grizzlies missing an attack in
the paint and look at the way fox
changes ends he puts it up and in and
draws a foul you're a more than one guy
to get back I mean this the speed at
which he plays you need multiple guys
the defenders feed it out of the way a
truce
scraped up my Fox Paul George didn't
want to pick up his sixth foul
quite right on the timing there here is
Fox full steam ahead down the lane using
that speed and finishes with the left
hand I hate when I hear that because
it's a lie because there's so much more
to care about but if you don't play
defense you don't care about winning
great finish